okay everyone we finally got the full
translated chapter of those insane
spoilers and a lot of new information
has come to light including about the
revolutionaries Sabo the death of Cobra
Shanks and more so make sure to stay
tuned for that Michelle parking with it
and smash that like button if you
enjoyed these one piece reviews and want
to keep them coming join the nakama by
subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss future
one-piece videos and updates and now
without further Ado let's jump into It
spoilers and all we jump where we left
off at kamabakka queendom where Sabo
explains talking to only ivanko and
dragon that all three objectives were
taken care of they officially declared
war by destroying the Celestial Dragon
symbol so in the spoilers I thought this
was a world government flag or something
but this is even better specifically
targeting the celestial Dragons It's
also interesting how it's the
Revolutionary Monkey D Dragon trying to
take down the celestial dragons dragons
dragons are associated with both sides I
wonder if that's a coincidence a lot of
dragons in one piece anyways Sabo adds
that they rescued Kuma which
unfortunately didn't last long since he
returned to marijuana himself but still
the fact that they succeeded there in
front of everyone freeing him even
temporarily is huge in and of itself and
thirdly they freed as many slaves as
possible which is great to hear they
even managed to find and destroy the
Holy land's food reserves which as I
mentioned in the spoiler video is great
to see love how they employ strategic
Warfare like this rather than just
trying to overpower the world government
physically and with the good comes the
other side too now they got the world's
attention and so the Navy ended up
sending in the big guns Dragon mentions
that they've triggered uprisings in 12
Nations where they held influence and
eight were successful and ivankov
mentions that one of those vanished
namely Lucia good to know there are
nations that successfully rebelled and
didn't vanish though I wonder if emu
thinks that that would be too much but
still wonder why the others weren't
erased so far although the headlines
censored everything we're told the seven
other nations have all declared their
intent to no longer pay the celestial
tribute or comply with the exploitative
exporting of their resources Oda is
really digging into politics here and
I'm loving it ivankov even says that the
Revolutionary Army is attacking World
Government Supply carriers all over the
world to stop resources reaching
marijuana and while the Revolutionary
Army is finally in action and in a big
way this one line by ivanko is great too
ivanko says they say the holy land's
high up location makes it an
impenetrable Fortress but we'll see how
they like living under siege they'll
finally get a taste of what it is to
live in poverty and go hungry end quote
and that line hits different I think
we'd all like a reality check for people
like Saint Charles who feel so entitled
and whose privileges bring suffering
upon others Ivanka wants to give them a
taste of their own medicine and this is
what the revolution is all about and I
love to see how excited ibanko gets not
being able to contain himself screaming
out Hee-Haw that enthusiasm is most
definitely infectious meanwhile Dragon
points out that they may not be able to
cut off all their supplies but they are
squeezing them slowly but surely they
must be struggling by now I love to see
the patients involved in these tactics
too it's not just about flashy wins but
also about slowly wearing them down and
it has to be like that when taking on
such a big entity like the world
government and the celestial dragons But
Here Comes one of the most interesting
parts of the spoilers now Dragon says as
expected though they're not a foe who
will just take all this lying down our
real battle will start when they
mobilize God's Knights which in the
spoiler video was holy nights but same
idea though here is where we see the
shanks looking shadow in the center
silhouette really and the figure has a
similar code to build and sword in the
same place since this is in the center
of the image this is probably not a
coincidence although a lot of people in
the comments don't believe this is
Shanks a lot mentioned it could be a
clone or a relative even twin brother
I've even heard theories that these
Knights could be clones of the strongest
fighters in his history which would make
them too overpowered probably to even
exist but a hype Theory nonetheless
people have also noticed that when shank
supposedly met the five Elders they
never showed his scar or missing arm
leading some to assume that this was the
Holy Night in question and not Shanks
very interesting stuff indeed and can't
wait to learn more about this hype new
group in all honesty aside from GARP the
Marines have been looking pretty weak
recently aokiji is now an enemy of the
world government revolutionaries
seemingly best two Admirals without
Dragon even being present it seems like
this new strong group was desperately
needed to make the world government an
actual superpower again but let me know
what do you think about this Shanks like
silhouette notably there are seemingly
nine Silhouettes so the holy nights are
more numerous than the Admirals it's
possible though that they will be broken
down further into stronger and weaker
categories we'll see but there will
definitely be some standouts among them
no doubt like the central Shanks like
one it's funny Bunko then says the Sabo
you realize you will will be their
number one target Sabo or should I start
calling you flame Emperor Sabo that's
hilarious and I still love that title
even if Sabo says I'm not too hot on
that name which hot fire flames it's
it's pretty pretty funny stuff dragon is
not shaken though and as I guess this
misunderstanding with Cobra was cleared
up very easily even though Oda teased us
that Dragon might butt heads with Sabo
over it he just says though here it
doesn't matter what the truth behind
Cobra's assassination is the news
reports have made you a hero already he
explains the in the eyes are
revolutionaries everywhere authority
figures within the world government are
hated for being subhuman however Dragon
notes that there are some intelligent
and fair rulers among them too and Cobra
was in a class of his own everyone
considered him to be an outstanding
ruler he said misinformation spreads
faster than nuances like this then Sabo
interrupts with a good point that it
might be cool to say but while he feels
bad for what happened to COBRA he thinks
he can live with the way this all played
out if it helps fuel the Flames of
rebellion his determined face says it
all and dragon calls him unshakable
ivankov like us is wondering what really
happened so begs him to spit it out the
truth ivanko shows him the paper on Sabo
above the dead body of Cobra and asks
what really happened and is there truth
in the story that he assassinated Cobra
ivankov says they shed tears trying to
figure out what happened and looking for
an explanation for it which in my view
is a bit extreme but okay I mean in my
view they got a trustable and put
revolutionary figures over authority
figures at the end of the day but Sabo
for his part looks surprised at the
picture before we jump to the flashback
we're taking back in time over a month
ago at the home of the Gods in the Holy
Land of marijuana where the
revolutionaries are attacking the
so-called land of the Gods which in
itself is quite an act just the idea of
so-called Gods being attacked by
Immortals is a thought-provoking idea
and a powerful image the celestial
dragons are shocked that they attacked
their beloved its symbol and now they're
taking away their Exquisite food you get
crazy remarks from Celestial dragons
like the following does the jealousy of
these Vermin know no bounds the figure
says he doesn't even want to keep their
heads after they are disposed of you see
a Celestial Dragon riding on the back of
a former crying pirate too and just as
the Celestial Dragon is about to walk
and fire the pirate by shooting him the
pirate slave is rescued by karasu one of
the commanders of the revolutionaries
the cool Crow aesthetic guy karasu takes
the celestial dragon's gun and asks who
do you think you are and all I can say
is Viva the revolution baby it is here
love to see them finally taking action
against all of these injustices the
celestial dragons thought they were
Untouchable for way too long so it's
good to see the revolutionaries finally
act and burst their bubble Karas was
blasted by Firearms but it doesn't
really matter because as we find out he
ate the suit fruit a seeming logia that
allows him to be unhurt by bullets and
so it seems his crows are just suit he
is shaping in that form and suit is a
black substance formed by combustion and
associated with smoke fitting for the
Revolutionary Army which is constantly
spoken of in terms of fire and karasu's
suit is produced metaphorically by the
Flames of Revolution so it's something
that accompanies these Flames meanwhile
we see cool cat revolutionary Commander
Lindbergh and Admiral fujitora karasu
goes to attack fujitora while Morley
stabs Admiral greenball through the hand
it must be said though he looks pretty
unhurt but he is angry Morley is calling
him a boy who likes to play rough which
is hilarious while Admiral Greenville
angrily says Morley is the one who is
destroying the city but the celestial
dragons are angry at the Admiral too
saying he's as bad with the damage he's
inflicting and one even insults Admiral
greenball saying he'll hang if any of
them get hurt green bull is clearly
worried saying it's impossible to fight
here and thinking get out of the way
already to the Celestial Dragon it's
clear even the Admirals are annoyed by
these entitled Celestial dragons
meanwhile fujitora cares way less than
Greenville and is great to see and he is
in the process of get this calling a
meteor strike that's so hilarious a
meteor strike while they're supposed to
be preventing damage he's even called an
idiot and told that's a terrible idea
but it's clear that this is limiting for
the Admirals because the revolutionaries
can go all out while the Admirals have
to try to avoid ruining the place and
hurting the celestial dragons so could
explain in part why the revolutionaries
were so successful they definitely
attacked at the right place it's even
said that there are two Admirals here
and if they were anywhere but the home
of the gods that would be more than
enough power to turn any Battlefield
upside down some cp0 agents appear
saying even if you ignore the handicap
the Revolutionary captains are doing
well to stand their ground definitely
High Praise Sable is shown that he sees
Kuma with Charles and his father Charles
also hasn't given up on getting Shira
she and making her his pet Sabo assures
morally that they won't let them get
away with it we even see Bonnie running
after her father Kuma in the flashback
then we get Vivi watched by Luchi and
she asks for GARP instead and I don't
blame her he's more trustworthy and
definitely more powerful she thinks it's
a joke that Lucci is watching her
because they didn't protect shirohoshi
then we see king cobra and he's about to
see the god of say but it's said only he
can enter so obviously it's looking like
the gorosei are going to kill this one
good ruler and honestly I can see why
he's a threat to them because he'd be
the first to flip sides and set a bad
example in their view for other good
rulers or at least not evil rulers the
naive Cobra tells Pele and Chaka that
this won't take long and to go out to
look for Vivi he says she's always been
a mischievous one so they can't let her
out of their sight which is some good
intuition someone should definitely be
watching baby right now the narrator
says what's the purpose of this meeting
and obviously it appears to to be the
murder of Cobra and potentially he even
said some things that made the gorse
decide to act immediately but from the
looks of it now I bet the gorus debuted
him as a threat for one reason or
another killed him and pinned it on Sabo
who happened to pass by the dead corpse
or something like that when the picture
was taken either way we are at a high
point where one of the most hyped groups
is taking action and Shining if you love
The revolutionaries like I do you won't
want to miss my Monkey D dragon and all
his commanders explained video link on
screen right now and in the description